that this bill contains a hundred and
fifty billion dollars to help those
states now Madam President I want to
raise tonight something that I
discovered about this bill just a few
hours ago that gives me real heartburn
and actually I believe reflects badly on
this United States Senate here's how we
distributed the funds to the States each
state regardless of population gets 1.2
billion dollars and then the remainder
of the money up to 150 billion dollars
is distributed to States based on
population now
you can question whether that's the best
and most effective way to to essentially
allocate resources when you're fighting
a corona virus like this which is more
intense in some places than others but
that's not my overall point this Mort
right now here's what we discovered that
the people of the District of Columbia
people of the nation's capitol were left
out of that formula they are fighting
the corona virus just like Americans in
every other state and city they are part
of other federal formulas for example
title 1 for education highway funds and
other federal formula dollars go to the
people of the District of Columbia they
have a population that is higher than
two of the 50 states there are more
residents of the District of Columbia
the nation's capital than the state of
Wyoming and the state of Vermont but
they were left out of that category that
they're usually put in and instead they
were put into a formula
with Puerto Rico the Virgin Islands
American Samoa and some of the
territories and the net effect of that
the net effect of putting the people a
nation's capital in that formula versus
the formula with the states will cost
the District of Columbia about seven
hundred million dollars and that's
because that other formula is based
entirely on population and Puerto Rico
has about three million people in it and
so when you put the District of Columbia
into that funding kettle into that
funding pot they get shortchanged 700
million dollars and that's the case even
though the people of the District of
Columbia the people of the District of
Columbia send the federal Treasury more
tax dollars than the people of 22 other
states let me say that again the people
of the District of Columbia send the IRS
more tax revenues than the people of 22
other states and yet when it came time
to write the formula for distributing
emergency funds under the coronavirus
they weren't part of the kind of funding
formulas they normally are now I asked
about this because I thought maybe this
would be a simple fix I mean surely in a
bill of two trillion dollars in
emergency relief we can do right by the
people of the District of Columbia and
not shortchange them 700 million dollars
and the answer I got back was no no no
this was not a mistake this was not an
oversight that Republican negotiators
insisted on shortchanging the people of
the District of Columbia and if I'm
wrong about that it would be a very easy
fix in an amendment that could be
offered by the majority leader and I'm
sure
accepted unanimously accepted
unanimously except for the fact that
this actually was a point that was
negotiated now Pratt Madam President I'm
not going to hold up a two trillion
dollar emergency rescue package that is
urgently needed by the country for this
but I think it's shameful
I think it's shameful then in a two
trillion dollar emergency rescue package
we would shortchange the people right
here in the nation's capital people who
we see coming into work every day many
of the federal employees who work day in
and day out for the federal government
many of them live here many of them live
in surrounding states many of them live
all over the country but for the people
who live here to shortchange them and to
do it intentionally is really outrageous
and so here we are coming together and
that's that's the right thing to do as I
said this bill has many many flaws and
many many problems I certainly wouldn't
have written it this way and I would
never have done wrong by the people the
District of Columbia the way this was
intentionally done apparently in this
bill but overall we need this bill for
the country we need it because we have a
national emergency both on the health
care front and the economic front so I
hope going away from here as we come
together and I hope we'll do the right
thing with with a large vote I hope
there will be some senators whoever were
part of negotiating that deal who said
no we're gonna shortchange the people of
our nation's capital I hope they will
feel a little bit ashamed and I think
all those people who didn't want to
change this provision which is easy to
change just like that should feel
ashamed this is our nation's capital the
people who live and work here deserve to
be treated by with respect
there's no United States Center who
represents the people District Columbia
some of us who live in the
surrounding areas work hard to do so I
just wish senators from the rest of the
country and especially in this case
apparently our Republican colleagues
would show a little respect for the
people who live in the capital of this
great country and I yield the floor
not a president the majority leader is
recognized
I ask unanimous consent the cloture
motion with respect to the motion to
proceed to HR 748 be withdrawn is there
objection
without objection I ask unanimous
consent the Senate proceed to the
immediate consideration of HR 7 for 8
further that the only amendments in
order be amendments to be offered by
Senator McConnell
1578 and senator south 1577
or their designee further that the
Senate vote on the South amendment was a
60-vote affirmative threshold for
adoption where they're following
disposition of the Sasse amendment the
McConnell amendment as amended if
amended be agreed to the bill as amended
be read a third time and the Senate vote
on the passage of the bill as amended
with a 60 affirmative vote threshold for
passage finally is passed the motion to
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table and that all roll call
votes in a series be thirty minutes in
length is there objection without
objection mm-hmm the clerk will report
the bill Calendar number 1 v 7 HR 748
and act to amend the Internal Revenue
Code of 1986 and so forth
Madam President I ask consent that I
proceed under my leader time without
objection so here we are colleagues for
the information of all of our senators
we will first vote on the adoption of
the Sasse amendment at a 60-vote
threshold and then our second and final
vote will be on passage of the Charis
Act also at a 60-vote threshold we're
going to pass this bipartisan relief
package send it over the house so they
can put it on the President's desk when
the Senate adjourns this evening our
next scheduled vote will be the
afternoon of Monday April the 20th of
course during this unprecedented time
for our country the Senate is going to
stay nimble as always we'll convene
regular profile
sessions and if circumstances require
the Senate to return for a vote
sooner than April xx we will provide at
least 24 hours notice our nation
obviously is going through a kind of
crisis that is totally unprecedented in
living memory
let's stay connected and continue to
collaborate on the best ways to keep
helping our states and our country
through this pandemic let's continue to
pray for one another for all of our
families and for our country
Madam President the Minority Leader is
recognized now madam president and I'll
speak for a little bit briefly the
legislation now before us is historic
because it is meant to match at a star a
crisis our health care system is not
prepared to care for the sick our
workers leave order Madam President our
workers our health care system is not
prepared to care for the sick our
workers are without work our businesses
cannot do business our factories lie
idle the gears of the American economy
have ground to a halt our country has
faced immense challenges before but
rarely so many at the same time over the
past few days the Senate has stepped
into the breach we packed weeks or
perhaps months of legislative process
into five days representatives from both
sides of the aisle and both ends of
Pennsylvania Avenue have forged that
bipartisan agreement in highly partisan
times with very little time to spare
it's been a long hard road with a
remarkable number of twists and turns
but for the sake of millions of
Americans it will be worth it it will be
worth it to save millions of small
businesses and tens of millions of jobs
it will be worth it to see that
Americans who have lost their jobs
through no fault of their own will be
able to pay their rent and mortgages and
put food on the table because we passed
the greatest expansion of insurance to
the employed to the unemployed in
decades it will be worth it to send
gloves and masks to our nurses and to
our doctors it will be worth it to send
ventilators and beds to our hospitals
and begin rebuilding the public health
infrastructure in America a Marshall
Plan in this new century for our medical
system it'll be worth it to save
industries from the brink of collapse in
order to save the jobs of hundreds of
thousands of Americans in those
industries it will be worth it to put
workers first it was a long hard road
neither side can be completely happy
with the final product but it will be
worth it and I'm damn proud of the work
we did over the past few days because we
put in the work because we tested the
limits of exhaustion because we didn't
immediately accept a bill drafted by
only one party the legislation before us
tonight is better better for our health
care system and the 65,000 Americans now
afflicted with colvin 19 better for our
workers better for our small businesses
better for our Indian tribes better for
our economy and better for the American
people and so I must thank my colleagues
on both sides of the aisle
especially the chairs and ranking
members and their staffs the past few
days have been filled with drama the
past few hours were no exception I know
a few of my Republican friends still
Harbor reservations about voting for
this legislation but when there's a
crisis of this magnitude the private
sector cannot solve it individuals even
with bravery and valor are not how
full enough to beat it back government
is the only force large enough to
staunch the bleeding and begin the
healing this is a time when the American
people need their government this is
what we were elected for the oath we
swear to the Constitution means we must
protect the general welfare of the
people
so let us marshal this government into
action there are millions of Americans
watching us right now at home on their
televisions separated from friends and
family fearful for their children in
their lively hoods unsure of when the
time will come when all of our lives may
return to normal
let us tell them tonight that help is on
the way that they are not truly alone
that this country that this Senate that
this government is here for them in a
time of dire need this is strange and
evil disease there is much we still
don't know about it and it is keeping us
apart
when we pass this bill instead of
hugging each other we'll wave from a
distance none of us can know when this
plague will pass the only thing we know
for sure is that we must summon the same
spirit that saw previous of generations
through America's darkest hours
fellowship sacrifice fortitude
resilience that is what it means to be
an American with that spirit this nation
faced down war and depression and fear
itself I have no doubt that once again
America will ultimately prevail
majority leader is recognized I called
up the substitute amendment 1578 and
asked that it be reported by number
without objection
the amendment will be reported by member
senator from Kentucky mr. McConnell
proposes an amendment number 15 78 the
senator from Nebraska is recognized I
call up amendment number 15 77 and ask
that it be reported by number without
objection the amendment will be reported
by member the senator from Nebraska mr.
sass proposes an amendment numbered 1577
to in the memberid 1578 questions on the
sass amendment I ask for the yeas and
nays is there a sufficient second there
appears to be the clerk will call the
roll mr. Alexander miss Baldwin mr.
Barroso mr. Bennet this is blackburn mr.
Blumenthal
mr. blunt
mr. Booker mr.
mr. Boozman
mr. Braun mr. Brown mr. burr
Miss Cantwell this is Caputo mr. Cardin
mr. Carper mr. Casey
mr. Cassidy miss Collins mr. Coons mr.
Cornyn miss Cortez mast Oh mr. cotton
mr. Kramer
mr. Crapo mr. Cruz mr. Danes his
Duckworth mr. Durbin mr. NZ miss Ernst
mrs. Feinstein mrs. Fisher mr. Gardner
mrs. Gillibrand
mr. Graham mr. Grassley miss Harris miss
Hassan
mr. Hawley mr. Heinrich mr. onoe mr.
Hoeven mrs. Hyde Smith mr. Inhofe mr.
Johnson mr. Jones mr. Caine mr. Kennedy
mr. king miss Klobuchar
mr. Lankford mr. Lahey mr. Lee
mrs. Leffler mr. mansion
mr. markey
mr. Perdue mr. Peters
mr. Portman mr. Reid
mr. rish mr. Roberts
mr. Romney thank you ms Rosen MS mr.
rounds mr. Rubio mr. Sanders mr. sass
mr. schat's
mr. Schumer mr. Scott of Florida mr.
Scott of South Carolina mrs. Shaheen mr.
Shelby miss cinema Miss Smith miss
Stabenow mr. Sullivan mr. tester mr.
Thoon mr. Tillis Mr Timmy mr. Udall mr.
Van Hollen mr. Warner MS Warren mr.
Whitehouse mr. wicker mr. Wyden mr.
young
[Music]
senators voting in the affirmative
Alexander Barrasso Blackburn blunt Braun
Kramer Danes NZ Fisher hyde-smith Inhofe
Johnson Leffler mansion McConnell Perdue
rich Rubio SAS Scott of Florida Scott of
South Carolina and wicker senators
voting in the negative Durbin shots and
Schumer Miz mcsalley hi mr. Bozeman
hi mr. rounds aye mr. tester no mr.
Whitehouse no mr. Lankford I
mr. Graham I
mr. Kennedy
mrs. Murray No
miss Ernst I miss Duckworth No
mr. Murphy No
mr. Booker No
mr. Roberts I
mr. Casey no
mr. Merkley no
mr. Jung I mr. Heinrich No
mr. Cruz I mrs. capito I
[Music]
mr. Kimmy I
mr. rich I Miss Smith no miss Cortez
masked oh no miss Hassan No
Ms Rosen No
this Baldwin no
mr. Cornyn i mr. Tillis I thank you mr.
Crapo I
mr. Peters no mr. Udall no mr. King no
mr. Lahey
no MS Harris no
mr. Gardner
No
mr. Jones now
mrs. Feinstein No
miss Warren No
Mr Sanders No
mr. Hoeven I mr. Cardin no miss
Klobuchar no mr. Warner
no this can't well no
mr. burr
ah
mr. Bennett no miss Stabenow no
mr. Reid No
mr. Cassidy aye
mr. Wyden No
mr. Moran I
mr. Coons no
mr. Portman I
mr. cotton aye
mr. Cain No
mr. Hawley I
mr. Carper No
miss her oh no no
mr. Blumenthal no
mrs. Shaheen no miss cinema No
mr. Van Hollen no
mr. Markey No
mrs. Gillibrand no mr. Shelby I mr.
Menendez
no mr. Grassley I
mr. Brown no
miss Collins No
mr. Sullivan i ms Murkowski i
are there any Senators in the chamber
wishing to vote or to change their vote
if not the yeas are 44 48 the 60-vote
threshold having not been achieved the
amendment is not agreed to
under the previous order amendment
number one five seven eight is agreed to
the cork will read the title of the bill
for the third time counter number one 5
7 HR 748 and act to amend the Internal
Revenue Code of 1986 to repeal the
excise tax on high-cost employer
sponsored health coverage the question
is on passage of HR seven four eight as
amended
is there a sufficient second there
appears to be the cart will call the
roll
mr. Alexander
miss Baldwin
until
[Music]
mr. Barasa mr. Bennett mrs. Blackburn
mr. Blumenthal
mr. blonde mr. Booker mr. Bozeman mr.
Brahn mr. Brown mr. Berger Miss Cantwell
mrs. capito mr. Cardin mr. Carper mr.
Kathie mr. Cassidy
miss Collins mr. Coons mr. Cornyn miss
Cortez Masto mr. cotton mr. Cramer mr
krepo mr. Cruz mr. Danes miss Duckworth
mr. Durbin mr. Enzi miss Ernst mrs.
Weinstein mrs. Fisher
mr. Gardner mrs. Gillibrand mr. Graham
mr. Grassley miss Harris miss Hassan
mr. Hawley mr. Heinrich mr. onoe mr.
Hoeven mrs. Hyde Smith's mr. Inhofe mr.
Johnson mr. Jones mr. Caine mr. Kennedy
mr. Kings Club a charm
mr. Lankford mr. Lahey mr. Lee
mrs. Leffler mr. mansion mr. markey mr.
MacConnell miss mcsalley
mr. Menendez mr. Marc Lee mr. Moran miss
Markowski mr. Murphy
mrs. Marie mr. Paul mr. Perdue mr.
peters mr. Portman mr. Reid mr. rich mr.
Roberts mr. Romney miss Rosen mister
rounds mr. Rubio mr. Sanders mr. sass
mr. schat's mr. Schumer mr. Scott of
Florida mr. Scott of South Carolina mrs.
Shaheen mr. Shelby MS cinema Miss Smith
miss Stabenow mr. tester mr. Thoon
mr. Tillis mr. Toomy mr. Udall mr. Van
Hollen mr. Warriner MS Warren mr.
Whitehouse mr. wick or mr. Wyden mr.
young
senators voting in the affirmative
Alexander Baldwin Barrasso Bennett
Blackburn Blumenthal blunt Bozeman Braun
Braun birth Cantwell Caputo Cardin
Carper Casey Cassidy Collins Coons
Cornyn Cortes Masto cotton Cramer Crapo
Danes
Duckworth Durbin NZ Ernst Feinstein
Fisher Gardner Gillibrand Graham
Grassley Paris Hassan Holly
Hirono Hoeven hyde-smith Inhofe Johnson
Kane Kennedy King Lankford's Leahy
mansion Markey mcsalley
Menendez Merkley Moran Murkowski Murphy
Perdue Peters Portman read rich Roberts
Rosen grounds Rubio Sanders says shots
Schumer Scott of Florida Scott of South
Carolina Shaheen Shelby cinema Smith
Stabenow Sullivan tester Tillis Van
Hollen Warner Warren White House wicker
Wyden young no senator voted in the
negative this club a charm is club a
char I mr. Booker mr. Booker i mrs.
Murray mrs. Murray
I
mr. Udall mr. Udall
mr. Toomy mr. Toomy I
you
you
you
you
mr. McConnell mr. McConnell I
mrs. Leffler mrs. Leffler I
mr. Heinrich mr. Heinrich I
mr. Cruz mr. Cruz I
you